bonjour bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
diagonale tv spéciale championnat du
monde féminin championnat du monde
féminin 2015 à sotchi en russie avec les
seizièmes de finale retour
nous allons suivre le match bien entendu
qui oppose marie sebag à l'ukrainienne
anna ou chez nina la numéro un française
qui avec les blancs dans la première
partie n'a pas réussi mieux que le nul
nul d'ailleurs partie nul assez rapide
on l'a vu en quinzaine de coups et donc
maintenant à l'aller noir avec
l'objectif de ne pas perdre cette partie
et pourquoi pas tenter de la gagner même
si bien sûr avec les noirs c'est plus
difficile pour tenter en cas de match
nul de jouer les tie breaks
voilà il faut absolument éviter la
défaite pour marie c'est back sinon ça
serait la sortie immédiate du
championnat du monde
c'est parti dans ce match retour avec
donc mari qu'elle est noire donc on
débute la partie en du côté noir pour la
suivre et l'ukrainienne démarre avec le
coup kalyev trois coups voilà coup très
souple un puisqu'en fonction la réponse
des noirs on peut même avoir une
sicilienne à imaginer que les noirs
jouent le coup c'est sec le pion ici en
c5 qu'on pourrait transposer dans une
sicilienne avait que quatre ça peut
arriver ça arrive quelques fois
voilà un coup assez souple mais par
exemple on aura pas de possibilité de
variantes ses miches par exemple qui
implique de jouer le coup à fond de f3
bon voilà donc une subtilité d'ouverture
des 5 g iii alors j'ai trois débuts de
type catalan la catalane fameuse catalan
on met le fou en g2 avec visé c'est
cette grande diagonale ici voilà donc
assez classique
kb les six fou j'ai 2
ces six voilà alors classique pour les
noirs aussi on oppose au positionnement
du fond blanc une chaîne de pions
extrêmement solide ici tout est sur
blanc le problème pour les noirs sera le
développement de ce fou parce que
évidemment si les pions sont sur blanc
on voit bien qu'il est enfermé derrière
ses pions alors pour l'instant il peut
encore sortir un f5 angers 4 mais on va
très certainement joué e6 est alors si
le fou est sorti mal placé il peut ce
fait pourrait se faire prendre
et s'il reste assez 8 il sera derrière
ses propres pions donc ce fou sera du
coup un problème pour les noirs donc
petit rock et donc fou g4 voilà donc fou
g4 et bien on résout le problème du fou
en proposant pourquoi pas plus tard de
l'échanger contre le khalife 3 attention
toutefois ça donnera la paire de fou aux
blancs d'oeuf ou contraints ici donc les
fameux fou père de fou qui en finale eux
permettent parfois de faire la
différence même souvent et puis
les blancs pourront jouer donc aussi
cavalli eu cinq attaquants se fout donc
c'est difficile de voilà donc s'il faut
tenir compte de cette possibilité mais
de l'autre côté on propose d'éliminer
problème du fou de jouer aux six
derrière
pourquoi pas donc on va voir ses quatre
alors classique les blancs commencent à
attaquer la pharmacienne de pucerons
avec un coup logique c4 est simplement
aussi soit la honte il on consolide ici
on perd pas de temps en prenant ces
quatre c'est pas une bonne idée de
prendre ces quatre trouver noirs ici
parce que les noirs et les blancs vont
l'attaquer avec tom câble et à trois
aussi c'est possible je pense d'ailleurs
qu'elle il ya 3 et puis les noirs
peuvent pas vraiment défendre et b5
parce qu'on pourrait sacrifier en b5 et
après la prise il suffit de jouer le
cavalier le fou ici mangerait la torah 8
voyez donc si on essaie s'accrocher au
pire on ne va pas regarder les variantes
à c'est pas le but aujourd'hui on va pas
faire les ouvertures mais si on essaie
de s'accrocher au pire on est bien on
affaiblit la grande diagonale et c'est
pas le but
parce que ce fou devient extrêmement
puissant et la torah 8 va avoir des
problèmes donc eu 6 voilà on consolide
et en plus on est prêts on prépare le
développement du foé suite des trois
logiques un regard des combles et blanc
mettre leurs pions eux mêmes sur blanc
puisqu'ils veulent ils veulent casser
cette structure pour libérer la force de
leurs fous et en jouant des trois on se
permet plus tard d'envisager des quatre
avec rupture en d5 forçant les noirs à
échanger ou permettant aux blancs de
tout est changé en d5 avec un fou g2 qui
devient fort voilà donc regarder quand
on joue des trois ehpad et 4 c'est une
possibilité
tout à fait intéressante fosse est
normal et sayed un b3 voilà donc dame b3
je rajoute un peu de pression sur des
saints bon pour l'instant si bien
protégé par des pions mais en
conjonction plus tard avec 4 ça peut
s'avérer décisif et puis j'attaque 17 le
foot en partie c'est le problème de
sortir le fou alors le fou ans et 8
quand elle sent solidaire ses pions mais
d'un autre côté ils empêchent les blancs
d'attaquer la faiblesse des sept voiles
et là les noirs met l'accent sur le fait
que le foot en sortie baisse était
faible
donc là marie joue le coup logique que
dame b6 vis-à-vis d'am-dam pas peur des
changes de dames puisqu'en cas deschamps
je reprends du pion bien sûr simple au
double et messi un pion qui se
rapprochent vers le centre c'est bon et
en plus ça libère la colonne à eilat
aura huit demi aqtim donc on n'a pas de
problème pour jouer d'un v6 et des
blancs eux refusent les changes de dame
n'doye dame c2 est en fait donc pourquoi
permettre d' imbéciles pour après jouer
dame c2 et bien sans doute parce que les
blancs ont dans l'idée de sortir leurs
fous plus tard par exemple en e3 avec
gain de temps sur la dame voilà ça c'est
une possibilité
voilà donc des cavaliers 17 très bien on
finit son développement pour marie et
asahi voilà fouet 3 on gagne en deux
temps sur la dame donc cette manoeuvre
qui a un peu tenté les blancs de m dames
en v6 permet de gagner un petit coup de
développement je vous ai trop à noter
que le fou est d'autant bien placés en 3
que le foie de verser tanger 4 voilà
parce que les normes n'ont pas le coup
le fameux coup qu'avaient les g4 qui
souvent attaque les fous placées en eux
trois voilà donc la foulée trois ont
fini son développement aussi du côté
blanc de façon souple et avec une bonne
classe pour le fou alors dams et 7 alors
à noter dans ce type de variantes
vis-à-vis d'am-dam qui peut être pénible
puisqu'en cas prises pour les blancs on
pourra pas reprendre du pillon c'est
notamment parce que la dame serait en
prison
il faut avoir ça en tête donc d'ailleurs
les blancs en profite tout de suite de
prendre et là on prend
du coup on veut qu'il ment échange
d'opinion on a libéré la semi colonnes
c'est maintenant ici sans doute les
blancs pourront jouer ensuite qui allie
ces trois voire cavaliers du 2
développement et harmonieux mais
n'auront pas de problème car les c3
voilà qu'à blesser 3 et puis combien
vis-à-vis d'hamdan qu'on l'a dit alors
peut-être décalé des singles pour
l'instant non parce qu'elle qualifie ce
qui protège mais des cavaliers b5 aussi
attention calais mais c'est qu'ils
attaquent la dame
bon c'est pas très grave ce cavalier en
bessin qu'une fois qu'on a joué la dame
il me menace rien mais attention il faut
avoir ça en tête va faire d'erreurs par
exemple faut pas jouer un coup comme
food et 6 des six calais b 5 la dame est
attaqué maintenant ça marche pas je suis
dit est ce que si on reprend évidemment
le fou protège la dame donc ça va je lui
dis des bêtises mais bon faut faire
attention à ce type de coups en tout cas
ça c'est sûr voilà fou prend très bien
fou bref trois pourquoi pas donc là les
blancs allaient noire des sites
d'échangés alors est-ce que c'était fort
c est ce que c'était obligé de jouer
aussi tofu prince trois noms ici les
noirs peuvent tranquillement jouer petit
rock et ne pas se presser de pour faire
cette prise pourquoi se presser bon
peut-être les noirs ont peur d'un coup
comme cavalier d41 le câble y viennent
en d4
pourquoi pas une possibilité et essayer
d'attaquer ce fou par h3g 4 ou f3 g4 je
sais pas et se fout après sera obligé de
venir à aussi si on le prendrait en six
ans cassard la structure blanche un
petit peu possible
donc vous prend vous prend pourquoi pas
hélas cabello 5 semble pas un mauvais
coup puisque sa menace simplement car
les points f3 avec échec et c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle pour les blancs
puisque on sera obligé de reprendre du
pillon faut pas laisser faire ça bien
entendu donc fou jets d'eau et la dame
17 ha alors sa dame 17 pourquoi alors
ici déjà c'est la menace qu'on disait
est faisable c'est à dire que là
d'ailleurs tiens je me demande sur
cavaliers là est ce que pouvait pas
prendre ici vous prend qu'est-ce qui se
passe ah oui bien sûr ça marche pas
parce qu'on reprend du pied ont tout
simplement on prend pas du cavalier mais
si on reprend du pillon et y'a rien à
perdre une pièce ça marche pas bien sûr
fou j'ai deux cavaliers là et simplement
bouger 2
donc là le problème c'est que les noirs
oui voilà les maintenant les blancs
menace cavale et prend des scènes voilà
c'est ça maintenant la menace c'est ça
c'est à dire que là si les noirs font
pas attention par exemple si les noirs
jouent au lieu de faire ça ils font
petit rock d'accord et bien simplement
les blancs gagne un pion maintenant par
cavalier prend calibre on peut pas
reprendre du pillon puisqu'il ya le
fameux vis-à-vis d'am-dam cas de foucque
calais prend fou prend voilà donc
attention c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
dès qu'on a des vis-à-vis d'am-dam il
faut être très prudent
donc là c'est pour ça que marie joue
pardon dame 17 pouces et 217 voix la
dame 17 évite cette manoeuvre mais sa
paire entend alors là très jolis coups
des blancs pour la suite food et 4 très
bien pas mal parce que le fou bon bien
sûr attaque le cavalier bon ça c'est pas
soit extrêmement grave mais le fou est
bien placé au centre et il n'a pas peur
les blancs n'ont pas peur d'un coup
comme ces cinq qui chasserait le fou
parce que d'abord le fou pour
éventuellement s'échangeait à 1 6 ess à
affaiblir et le centre noir qui quand
même est sous le feu du cavalier c3 du
fou g2 qui attendent que ça que cette
structure de pions ici commence à bouger
il faut avoir ça en tête qu'avec g6 et
la très très jolis coups des noirs un
peu contre intuitif mais je pense assez
fort torah d un an la 3d un vis-à-vis
tour dames vous dire il ya beaucoup de
pièces entre les deux oui mais ça l'idée
des blancs c'est de jouer le 4 e 4 avec
balla cavaliers pions foucque attaque
des cinq menace de casser la structure
noir avec derrière si on prend on sera
obligé tôt ou tard de reprendre du plomb
avec les noirs et le food et 4 sera
indélogeable il est magnifique ce fou en
d4 vise le rock
il est au centre il est superbe une fois
qu'on a joué le 4 et le prendre des 5
c'est fort et si les noirs prennent à
eux quatre cantons jeu 4 et bien on se
retrouve après des prend 1,4 avec un
vis-à-vis tour dames extrêmement pénible
voilà donc c'est déjà déjà difficile en
fait pour les noirs ici
donc le développement noir qui consiste
à jouer dame b 6 dames c'est cette
maintenant dan 17
c'était pas forcément les meilleurs
manoeuvre on voit bien qu'avec les noirs
là on est en retard on à tour par ok le
centre commence à me poser des problèmes
4 et tout de suite une menace et les
blancs par contre ont fini leur
développement
il n'ya plus que la tour et fin rentré
en jeu mais tout est fini quoi le rock
effet tout est en place
alors là marie joue h5n1 le coup h5n1
avis un peu un peu faiblard parce que
alors elle veut attaquer du côté droit
alors mais c'est pas elle qui elle tient
pas le centre ça le problème c'est que
le centre et n'est pas tenu par les
noirceurs pour attaquer sur l'ale il
faut être sûr que le centre va pas
s'ouvrir surtout quand on a pas ok donc
là elle joue h5 à l'ats par ok
on se demande si elle va pas s'affaiblir
encore plus quoi ici là parce que le
plan des blancs arrive de 4 lors de
questions nous prendre du plomb puisque
après puis on prend puis on prend
vis-à-vis tour dames on sera obligé
encore une fois de jouer la dame parce
que la menace fou prendre cavaliers avec
la tour kataka dame arrive donc s'il
faut pas surtout pas ouvrir le jeu ici
on may vary continue son plan h4 bon
pourquoi pas un jeu contre attaque sur
le roi pas de problème mais on va mettre
le centre saute on va on voit tout de
suite après eux prendre des cinq les
noirs ici elles sont dans la panade
alors pourquoi imaginons que les noirs
ici reprennent en dessin ce qui paraît
logique
par exemple par s'éprendre les cinq
simplement regarder s'est défendu le
dessin que par cavalier dame d'accord et
s'est attaqué par le fou g2 lecavalier
c3
donc il est perdu il suffit de faire le
simple fou prend m6
et après fou preuve si ce n'est noir
simplement on a gagné un pur net le pion
des qui en plus est un pion pas ses
protégés par une tour d un
et en plus on a la menace câbles hypron
m6 qui brise le rock c'est pénible
donc voyez que là on voit très vite que
c'était seul plan de marie semble quand
même faiblard c'est difficile ça aux
rousses et qu'elle a fait une erreur
le développement de la dame lui a fait
perdre du temps et les blancs ont
extrêmement bien joué le début sans
faire de fautes et en jouant de façon
très très responsable et très forte au
centre on a vu avec ce coup tu auras d1
kippa qui n'est pas facile à voir qui
menaçait e4 avec on voit ici une forte
pression centre donc après h4 peut
prendre des 5 v mari se résout à perdre
le pion en jouant simplement petit rock
voilà un petit rock et du coup on voit
bien que cette histoire d'âge 5 h 4 bon
c'est vrai que ça va affaiblir un peu
leur que blanc est est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour
pour le pion qu'on a donnée au centre en
plus non je veux pas sur moi les blancs
sont bien les blancs sont même plutôt
plutôt très bien donc faut prendre six
maintenant pour les blancs on sait bien
jouer aussi vous allez voir pourquoi
après fou prend m6 et bien les blancs
simplement ajouté quatre voilà il
remplace le fou par le pioneer qui met
en mouvement tout de suite leurs pions
passé comme le fou gêné l'avancée du
pion ils ont une option de plus les
blancs est effectivement pour valoriser
un pion de plus il faut l'avancé le plus
loin possible
surtout quand il est passé alors là il
n'est pas vraiment tout à fait passer
enfin tôt ou tard les blancs monts
prononcée 6,6 les blancs sont obligés de
reprendre ses six avec le fou qui
attaquent le pion ses six salles à tour
derrière ce pur c6 va devenir une fête
une faiblesse aussi voilà il va être
attaqué avec une case csn que les blancs
peuvent à envahir par cavalia quatre
câbles et c5 qui attaquera la dame
c'est pénible mais c'était l'ère collard
effectivement c'est dur là c'est dur
voilà et les blancs spreads se sont pas
à presser de prendre ces six parce que
ils voulaient pas que les noirs prennent
position sur la case des quatre voilà
ils jouent eux-mêmes des 4 cyl blanc
prennent de toute façon ils prendront du
cavalier attaquant fou voilà donc c'est
dur pour les noirs déjà de trouver des
bons coups alors marie trouve quand même
des coûts correcte elle fait tour à des
bon pourquoi pas tu auras des huit
j'essaie de balades et de contrer ce qui
se passe au centre mais qui on prend ces
six qui on prend 6,6 et simplement des 5
voilà donc la halle et le pion alors il
n'est pas passé puisqu'on a pu on a
repris du poids on sait et les blancs se
résolvent ici bon pourquoi pas c'est pas
forcément le
ce pas mal les blancs échange un pion
isolés contre notre pions isolé là les
noirs sont obligés de prendre son cola
le pion vad vraiment de venir passer un
prêt et puis on prend 6,6 s'éprend des
cinq cavaliers prend et voilà le
capitaine prenable il attaque le fou et
6 il ya un vis-à-vis tour dames et le
pion de plus maintenant il est de ce
côté là on a deux pions contraint donc
virtuellement on a un pion passé ici
voilà s'il est pas au centre meunier sur
le côté dames g4 follet fallait enlever
le vis-à-vis mais forcément du coup on
voit bien que là le problème c'est ce
qui va suivre
c'est que évidemment on pourrait prendre
s'ils arrivent 6 avec un doublement des
pions bon les blancs font attention
puisque effectivement bon il ya quand
même ce pur h4 est que quand même une
manoeuvre qu'il faut pas négliger de la
part des noirs c'est une contre attaque
de marie puisqu'il peut se passer des
choses contre au roi blanc qui pourrait
lui-même devenir faible alors notamment
si on prend aussi son propre en dû
plonger le roi pourrait venir angers7
et on pourrait mettre une tour sur la
colonne h bon il pourrait se passer des
trucs
même si la position blanche est
extrêmement solide je pense que des
blancs devraient pas craindre une
attaque de ce type là c'est eux qui ont
l'avantagé au centre donc c'est eux qui
doivent attaquer alors h3 pour faire
fuir cette dame qui est quand même
menaçante avec un pion h4 une dame bon
mais on a fait bill rock c'est un peu
tout secoué un client je suis pas c'est
pas forcément le meilleur
mais bon ça quand même il faut jouer
avec les noirs dames 6
et on revient à m6 de nantes aurait fait
1 la dernière pièce des blancs se met en
jeu en attaquant la dame et l'allée
n'auront pas beaucoup de coups très
difficile de trouver un coup dans cette
position faire attention
alors mari joue un coup intéressant
damas six et donc il faut arriver à
tenir ce type de position inférieure
mais bon c'est pas encore perdu c'est à
dire que là les blancs ont l'avantagé
nettement bon avantage veut pas dire
partie gagnée bondam à six attaques à 2
mine de rien c'est jamais même si ça a
l'air dangereux de prendre à deux
puisque tours à 1 et où va la dame l'e3
est contrôlé par adam adverse c4 est
contrôlé par dame inverse et le cavalier
des scènes qui est protégé par le fou g2
donc ce pion est vraiment pas attaquer
de façon
absolue venir et qu'il ya une menace
mais qui pour se concrétiser demande à
ce qu'au moins une tour soit échanger de
façon que ce que tours ne soit pas
possible donc c'est pas une vraie menace
est là très fort coût des blancs qui
pour l'instant joue quasiment tous les
meilleurs coups fouet son attaque la
dame le fou a fini son travail sur cette
colonne
il joue en f1 peut-être plus tard il
pourrait venir en ses cadres et puis
surtout le problème c'est que où va la
dame noire
on peut pas prendre à deux on vient de
le voir à cause de toi un et la dame a
non pas taurin cette fois ah oui non sur
cabaye sur damas deux d'emprunt à 2 il y
aura sans doute qu'avec ses trois jeux
on va le faire sur dame prend à deux ou
encore aux cavaliers pros m6 échec
oui et encore plus fort il ya cavaliers
ah oui c'est très fort simplement on
fait cavaler preuve six échecs
puis on prend c'est une manoeuvre de
techniques et la regarder pousser 4
tranquillement j'ai enlevé le cavalier
en fait pour pouvoir avoir le fou ici
qui attaquent la dame et qui cloue le
pion f7 ce plan est cloué donc la dame
doit bouger parce qu'elle est en prise
et la menace en plus ces dames pranger
six gardes et magnifique échec au roi
puisque le pion f7 et cloud est donc en
fait une double menace terminée marie
pourrait faire ses valises et c'est pas
forcément c'est pas c'est pas bon c'est
pas ça qu'il faut faire
donc faut f1 dame bessette
elles se trompent pas elle fait pas
l'erreur d'aller prend on me prenait
convient de voir la manoeuvre il ya une
piège derrière donc là
cavalier prend ici c'est chez quand même
de la part des blancs c'est bien
puisqu'après gpra m6 et blanc semble
avoir tout pour eux un pion de plus de
contrat ici et des pions doublé du côté
noir alors le seul la seule petite
contrechamp ce convoi pour les noirs
c'est que ils ont poussé ce pion
jusqu'en h4 donc ce pillage qui est
potentiellement qui aurait été isolé
même position et qu'un pion h il aurait
été isolée mais là il peut s'échanger à
tout moment contre g3 donc c'est pas
très très très grave et le roi blanc
pourrait être un peu faible mais tout de
suite il n'est pas vraiment faible fou
de cases blanches le protège bien ça
semble difficile quoi donc là il y en a
quand même extrêmement nette 1 pour les
blancs
c'est dur il faut juste pas se tromper
du côté noir alors la chance aussi pour
marie c'est qu'après fou j'ai deux dames
b6 roi h23 g7 et les noirs les blancs et
les noirs pardon simplement améliore la
position de leurs droits respectifs
puisque là le roi protège la case g3 le
roi m6 protège m6 et puis on sait jamais
pourquoi pas permet à une tour de venir
sur la colonnade même si pour l'instant
tout est bien tenu il simplement b3
voilà dans cette position ce qu'il faut
voir c'est ce qu'on voit pas sur
l'échiquier
c'est que les deux deux joueuses
commençait transit note voilà ça c'est
important à comprendre c'est à dire que
là au niveau du temps il en reste
quelque chose comme moins de 10 minutes
chacun pour jouer dick ou alors faut
savoir aussi qu'à chaque coup il ya
trente secondes qui sont rajoutés la
pendule ce qui fait cinq minutes de plus
donc c'est là la seule quart d'heure
pour dikoumé un quart d'heure pour du
coup ça fait qu'une minute et demie par
coup
bon ça commence à être restreint coin
rien de panique ans mais ça il faut
jouer maintenant de façon un peu plus
rapide que ce qu'elles ont pu faire les
joueuses jusqu'ici donc la marie joue un
bon coup pour des quatre tours des
quatre c'est bien l'idée est simple ces
doubles et les tours en voilà cette tour
est fluide ne joue pas failli trouver un
moyen d'activer donc marié a décidé de
prendre la colonne des ou à plancy les
blancs jouent ce qui fait dans la partie
ce qui est fait la partie par uche et
nina tout reprend décadent prend des
quatre si les blanches autour des 1 pour
attaquer la dame noire sur cette colonne
des simplement on prend la colonne eux
voilà dans le cinq
hélas les blancs peuvent plus opposés à
une pièce lourde alors c'est très bien
que la dame soit 1,5 puisque forcément
vous voyez bien que elle vise le roi en
conjonction avec un pion h4 qui
attaquent g3 donc là on commence à voir
des petites idées d'affaiblissement du
roi blanc
d'un autre côté aussi se caler g6
finalement défend très bien droit noir
qui est bien placé en gsm qui contrôle
très bien f6 et f7 et puis un doublé on
sait qu'il faut pas trop les bouger mais
qu'en défense sont d'excellents
défenseurs donc les noirs risque pas
grand chose du côté roy il faudrait pour
les blancs très certainement pour
prendre l'aventage de façon nette et
mettre en avant leur avantage en fait
faire jouer leur majorité ici deux
contre un mais c'est pas simple parce
qu'il faut à la fois faire ça tout en
faisant attention ce que vont faire les
noirs pour aller essayer d'affaiblir
leur roi et c'est toujours désagréable
d'avoir un roi attaque et on le sait
bien
aux échecs ce qui compte c'est avant
tout le matin c'est pas les pousser les
pions
donc attention
marie aime bien avoir des positions
d'attaquants plus une attaquante hors
pair donc commence à se dire bon c'est
vrai que les blancs sont clairement
mieux mais on voit bien qui a dit quand
même du jeu un petit peu de jeu pour les
noirs possible il faudrait qu'il faut
pas que les blancs face d'erreurs et là
miracle les blancs se trompe
complètement de pions de plans de parrot
partons de ce plan il aurait fallu sans
doute qu'ils jouent aussi des coups
comme tour 17 pour aller sur la septième
attaque et a72 plus en plus ça serait ça
serait le rêve est bon ils ont eu peur
peut-être de l'attak ou ici et donc elle
joue un coup ici les blancs faut 4 alors
c'est pas terrible ce conte moi je pense
se couvre déjà c'est une première erreur
de la part des blancs une diminuer un
peu leur avantage l'idée c'est peut-être
de dire bon je vais changer ce cavalier
g6 qui peut être une c'est vrai qu'une
dame est un cavalier contre rouyn c'est
toujours pénible parce que on trouve
toujours des coups un peu inattendu avec
des attaques de maths c'est vrai mais
échangent et se fout quand on se
canalise ces mauvais à deux titres
1 ça enlève un défenseur durable en donc
en fait il finit au lieu de dar le jeune
attaquant surtout s'affaiblit le roi
donc une fine et ça enlève pas les
possibilités d'attaqués des noirs les
deux en finale installèrent au cas où
les blancs arrive à échanger les dames
un final le fou est quasiment tout le
temps supérieur aux cavaliers
surtout quand il ya des pions des deux
côtés comme ça deux îlots de pions un
îlot de pion à bb contre e1 et e3 ici
contre 2 donc le feuilleton passionnant
supérieur aux cavaliers donc c'est pas
une bonne idée de les changer mais il
supérieur en finale et donc deux
j'enlève un défenseur du roi donc je
pense que coûte un mauvais coup et la
mari s'y trompe pas tranquille va tu
veux prendre le cavalier mais prend le
moi je joue tours 8 voilà continue son
idée de prendre la colonne e d'activer
sa tour tout simplement
cette tour jouait pas maintenant les
jours alors qu'est ce que tu fais ce que
tu vas prendre angers 6 si les blancs
prenaient angers 6 il n'y a pas de
problème pour les noirs imaginons
ici foot prendre cavalli g6 la noire
pourrait jouer par exemple
d'abord pourquoi pas puis on prend les
trois échecs comme pranger 3 et même
tour deux échecs
voilà tout simplement force d'un
programme quasiment tout reprend échec
et après roy h1 simplement maintenant je
prends du roi est pas du pion parce que
sinon je me prends 2 tours 17
emma tour est extrêmement bien placé
très active
ado est attaqué et les blancs voient
leur avantage quasiment réduit à néant
parce que là on le final de tout on sait
que sont quasiment toutes nul c'est très
difficile à gagner et la tour active je
dirais qu'on pense presque le pion de
moins sur tous les bancs et là ils sont
obligés quasiment de jouer mais pas à 4
parce que sur à 4 simplement tour toro 3
et puis b3 et g3 son attaque et donc
c'est pas une bonne idée et tour un bon
ben on voit bien que la tour 1 n'est pas
fier parce que là on va jouer f5 f4 on
va jouer le roi noir on va à l'avancé on
va voir créer peut-être des menaces
déchets cloud et c'est le roi va être
très actif et au final les noirs vont
arriver sans doute à faire nul assez
facilement donc tours 8
foulée 2 voilà on voit bien que du coup
les blancs perdu du temps voilà donc
c'est là qu'on voit que ici on sent que
la position commence à se retourner ou
g2 on se dit que ben est pas si mal quoi
pour les noirs là c'est plus la même et
non c'est plus la même voyez qu'on me un
seul coup je dirais un peu douteux fait
que la position peu changé d'âme il ya
marie seront pas très jolies dames 2
voilà voilà elle connaît très bien ses
classiques
une dame sur la deuxième qui menace en
plus le pion à f2 ça laisse pas trop de
choix pour les pour les blancs il faut
protéger un tour d2 pas échangé puisque
la tour pareil seraient venus en deux
ans on aurait récupéré soit f2 soit à
deux avec une excellente position
tournée de demain la main pas de
problème pour marié maintenant les
pièces noires sont dans le camp blanc et
c'est plus la même le pion de plus c'est
moins grave
ce qui compte maintenant c'est la
pression qu'exercent les noirs sur sur
le roi ce qui laisse pas trop le temps
aux blancs de sa de faire joujou avec
leurs pions tour des uns et la marie se
trompent pas le pourrais répéter en
disant des dames 2 à thouars qu'est ce
que tu fais non elle va jouer pour le
gabarit mais oui tours 2 elle sait très
bien que l'activité de ces pièces fait
plus que compenser son pion - c'est ça
qu'il faut savoir c'est l'activité est
souvent supérieure au matériel donc tout
reprendre et quasiment forcé enfin
efforcés tout reprend et maintenant
c'est fini les noirs vont récupérer un
pion puisque les deux sont attaqués à
noter que si que les blancs peuvent même
pas jouer tout recettes pour aller sur
la 7ème puisque le cavalier protège bon
de toute façon ce serait une mauvaise
idée puisque la tour prend à deux
protège à 7 en plus
donc là les blancs se résolvent à jouer
à quatre bons essais faiblard parce
qu'on voit tout de suite que c'est pas
pareil
les pions là le pion b3 est faible bon
mais on a évité la prison - bien sûr et
la tour prends un f2 et on voit bien que
laurent blanc mine de rien est faible
voilà ça y est il est faible le plein de
marie qui a été de d'essayer de mettre
un peu de pression sous du côté droit
pour compenser fini par fonctionner
grâce à ce coup un peu douteux qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure vous aux 4b
heureusement on est là on commence à
respirer l'eusec noter toujours là à
noter en est encore aux trente huitième
coup pour tours 3 hélas les joueuses il
leur reste 30 secondes à la pendule
chacun faut pas se tromper
donc c'est le moment où la gaffe
pourrait même retourner la situation à
leur tour b 2-3 g1 pour enlever le
clouage 1 puisque la tour clouvel fou il
faut que ce fou juin parce que on va pas
jouer et on tard ce qu'elle va rentrer
en jeu il faut pas jouer avec les
avec les blancs bien entendu avec une
pièce virtuel de moins-16 si on n'active
pas notre fou il a tranquillement mon
mari f5 vassal et joue pour le gain
c'est incroyable bon alors évidemment
les blancs sont toujours
sans vent réel danger de perdre ici à
l'égalité de fait existe mais en termes
je dirais de style les c'est bon pour
marie parce que l' avantage de
l'initiative on va dire le jeu est du
côté noir c'est les jeux c'est les noirs
qui font le jeu ici c'est les noirs qui
sont actifs
c'est le roi blanc qui est sous la
menace de la tour qui plus est il est là
deux pions pour le défendre contre trois
du côté noir donc il ya des menaces de
déchets que des petites combines qui
peuvent avoir lieu qui sont à l'avantagé
des noirs mais bon sur un bond de jeu on
se dit que comme le fou est supérieur
aux cavaliers quand même bon il
difficile quand même de mater dans ce
type de parti l'anc comme une des pièces
sur noir pour pour menacer des maths bon
mais attention il peut se passer des
trucs g prend h4 pour la part des blancs
moutons se séparent
très bien et la main il joue quand même
f4 attaque lattois en 3d où va la tour
pas évident si on vient à f3 avec la
tour eh bien on pourrait quand même
prendre 11 h 4 puisque le pion f4 et pas
prenable à cause de tout reprend fou
échec même cavalier prend août au plan
politique c'est encore mieux
voilà le le cavalia et latour
attaquerait le fou j'ai 2 voilà donc ici
tour c3 est quasiment forcé cavaliers
prend h4 alors regardez ce que ce qu'il
faut noter ici c'est la complémentarité
du pion et du cavalier lecavalier pro tu
attaques ces deux cases donc notamment
le foot en prison ici attention tour
cavaliers attaque le fou et puis le pion
f4 contrôler les cases g3 et de trois
regardez la force
voilà tout ça est bon c'est quand même
très très désagréable quand on est blanc
d'avoir tout ça contre contre son ombre
donc il faut jouer extrêmement précis la
moindre erreur pourrait se retourner
contre les blancs donc food et 5 très
bon coup va très bien on vient attaquer
f7 avec des menaces pourquoi pas de
venir en f1 en ces sept avec la tour et
de ramasser tous c'est très bien il faut
activer le fou à noter aussi que ce fou
protège b3 donc ça peut libérer la tour
donc c'est un bon coup et la très jolie
coup de marie sebag ici qui s'embarrasse
pas d'un des deux détails
bref si ce magnifique en fait elle se
moque du pion et 7 mai sur le garde le
roi au contact mais surtout elle
centralise son rang elle venir en scène
pourquoi pas en d4
et si la tour s'en va venir entre 3 et
participé à un réseau potentiel de maths
il peut se passer des matelas par là
laurent blanc est quand même dans un
coin là il peut se passer des trucs donc
très dangereux
galets blancs commencent à craquer un
peu aussi à 5 très faible très faible à
5 bons en milieu de jeu on avait dit
c'était l'idée c'était d'essayer de
mettre en mouvement cette cette majorité
il ya une majorité toujours et on va
bien qu'à 5 c faiblard et défendu par
yes ce pion peut se faire attaquer à
n'importe quel moment bon le ça paraît
faible
ça paraît faible à la place dassin que
les laits blanc aurait sans doute été
inspiré de jouer un coup comme tour
c'est cette menace tout reprend tout
reprend et peut-être ya des menaces de
match mais je peut sacrifier même le fou
contre le pion et touré cavalli contre
tours on a déjà parlé
samat pas philidor l'expliquent dès le
xviiie siècle pour ceux qui me
connaissent pas mais tout est calé
contre tours ça ne m'aide pas tours est
fou c'est pas la même mais touré
cavaliers ça c'est pas possible
trop difficile enfin de fond romain des
cas faut vraiment faire exprès quand
donc la a5 faiblard et l'as rome 5
n'empêche pas les noirs d'amener leur
recentrons laisse le pion et cette année
comme harry sebag ici n'a pas peur de se
faire prendre le pion et 7
alors là le coup qui suit est
intéressant c'est pas mal fou détroit
pardon tour des 3 l'idée de tour des 3 b
c'est d'empêcher le roi de venir en d4
voilà c'est pas tellement de l'eiblen
comprennent aussi que prend nos points 7
rebonds si on peut le prendre c'est bien
mais c'est pas le plus ancien le plus
essentiel c'est que là le roi noir
devenait menaçant quoi donc tour des 3
le roi est coincé voilà je peux pas
passer ni en 4 n'ayant des quatre la cia
en plus mon bien sûr ça protège le fou
mais d'idées c'est surtout d'empêcher le
roi noir d'aller plus loin
donc là marie est au maximum de son
potentiel le pion f4
et bien placé les proches du roi blanc
est passé il peut menacer des trucs à
tout moment la tour est bien placée
puisqu'elle empêche le pion b2 d'avancé
puis on a sept faut pas qu'ils bougent
il va pas aller sur une case blanche
puisque le foot cases blanches à hirel
prendre donc il est bien pour aller
chercher suit la forêt s'affaiblir il
faudra enlever à mener la tour en la 7e
pourquoi pas mais du coup ça laisse les
noirs avaient des menaces sur le roi
blanc et puis bon il reste soit le pion
9,7 soit le cavalier parce que kavita la
bande ici à activer donc on peut
envisager ici pourquoi pas de jouer des
coups comme m6 voir f5
regardez nos deux pions bon c'est des
pions lier les avancées générales c'est
pas pas toujours une bonne idée mais ça
pourrait être intéressant pourquoi pas
de jouer f5 c'est de garder les deux
comme ça si l'on avance l'autre sera
toujours là et on évite de le donner
gratuitement mais on peut aussi jouer ce
que je vous mariez qui est aussi un très
bon coup kalyev 5 voilà qu'elle est
c'est un conte centralise le cavaly
voilà parmi les deux pièces qui
demandait à être activées ici avec sur
le carré sur le pion counting pourquoi
pas alors là les bleus craque
complètement puisqu'il vous b4 grosse
erreur pourquoi donner le pion parce que
les blancs ont peur
on n'est plus aux et notent pourtant on
a passé le 40e 48e coup pardon donc il
reste plus de 30 minutes ou joueuses qui
ont été rajoutées à leur pendule plus 30
secondes par coup toujours qu'elle avait
le temps l'ukrainienne de réfléchir elle
a pris le temps de réfléchir mais bombay
4 ça donne un pion et ça donc pas
n'importe quel pions des deux majorités
de ce côté là mais elle avait peur à la
peur
elles menacent ils ont deux pouces et
elle veut que la tour s'en aille parce
qu'elle sent que son roi risque des
choses sans quoi la raison c'est
extrêmement difficile en plus de
calculer ça il reste peu de temps il
peut se passer n'importe quoi bon c'est
chou donc la marine google prend
tranquillement mais on l'a maintenant
bel avantage a changé de camp parce
qu'après fou prend f7 pour récupérer un
pion regarder le bilan des courses de
pions du côté noir deux pions du côté
blanc c'est égalité mais le roi noir lui
et centralise et indique le roi blanc et
à la bande il peut toujours se prendre
des échecs et il pourra pas vraiment
monter dans le clan adverse
il est sous pression les pions blancs
sont des cibles se faire attaquer
celui-là ce pion peut se faire attaquer
d'ailleurs pas retrouver celle par
exemple ici c'est une possibilité pour
marie c'est parce qu'elle a fait mais
tombé 5 empêche un tour échec qui
protégerait le pion donc il faudrait
protéger par tour à 3 et la tour serait
passive en a trois si on joue si on joue
à six tours à 5
regardez cette variante à six tours à 5
et 6 par exemple fous ces quatre pour
dire ben je conteste du fou ben ça
marche pas parce qu'il ya cavaliers 3
tout simplement et ovales fou il peut
pas venir en bessengué latour faut s'en
aller et le pion à 6 et perdu aussi vous
voyez c'est chaud quand même un ici
trois à quatre
après pardon supra f7 on va voir que
marié va justement majorque 4 la
position est clairement à l'avantagé des
noirs donc d'une position nettement
inférieur marie a d'abord réussi à
égaliser par l'initiative suite a aussi
à une imprécision blanche on l'a vu ce
fameux fouet 4 qui sans doute une
mauvaise idée stratégique et elle
s'active le coutour b5 il avait l'air
très intéressant pour marie
malheureusement on n'a pas joué un autre
coup intéressant ici est sans doute le
simple cavaliers e3 est bien aussi voilà
qu a lieu trois ça empêche aussi des
tours des scènes ça peut menacer tourbe
et 5 où tour à 4 qui semble-t-il gagne
le pion à 5
et puis ça amène un cavalier proche du
roi blanc on ne sait pas trop ce qui
peut se passer l'un sait pas trop ce qui
peut se passer
c'est assez désagréable bon mari joue à
notre coup intéressant quand même c'est
après vous pourrez peut-être ces trois
ou quatre valeureux quatre attaques la
tour
moi ce que j'aime pas dans 15 6 1 mais
le roi et le cavalier sur la caisse du
fou maintenant c'est sûr mari marc bien
venir en f3 pour menacer des maths on
comprend qu'on prend l'idée c'est sûr
que menacer des maths c'est toujours
agréable
elle veut aussi protéger l'avancé
potentiel de son pion mais ce fou
efforts donc venir sur cases blanches
bon alors ceci dit c'est quand même
intéressant parce que des coûts faiblard
de type par exemple essayons de voir des
coûts
un peu faible comme tours d2 tient
autour des 2 tours d'eads aurait été
faible puisque tour des deux permet roi
le 3 la tour bouge par exemple en la
maintenant où c'est pas évident on va
dire en c2 pour garder le contrôle de la
seconde rangée et maintenant f3 f3 et
c'est plus la même ce pion devient
menaçant menace de faire dame tourbe est
un échec le roi vient sera obligé de
venir en h2 avec f2 qui suit on sera
obligé de sacrifier le fourbe on voit là
ça devient chaud on croit que quatre
hélas les déblais seront peints ils
jouent le seul coût possible dans la
position qui qu'il a fallu revenir dans
la partie se courra au 4 et un pas sans
doute pas le meilleur tour des huit
voilà fallait venir un des 8 et pas
ailleurs
alors passez pourquoi un des huit parce
qu'on peut encore faire des échecs on
peut menacer fou échec aussi alors que
si la tour était venu par exemple en 17
c'est possible aussi bon mais le
cavalier empêche qu ici la tour de
douchez et on peut jouer simplement 3 3
avec des menaces de matin quasiment
c'est quasiment ma tombe bien il ya plus
que h deux compositions torje deux
échecs 3g on peut venir en g3 et là on
me laisse vraiment mat
voilà moi c'est un match du couloir
carrément bas du couloir avec en plus le
cavalier qui peuvent venir se joindre à
l'attack soit en trois soirs venir en
quatre pour venir en métro avec un échec
et il ya encore il ya des matches
possibles c'est c'est extrêmement
pénible donc tour des huit
tourbes et un échec bref deux tombés
deux échecs 3,20 pour les blancs à noter
que ici attention si les blancs étaient
revenus en juin
la partie est perdue puisque la marie
enfin perdu on peut les noirs un
avantage puisqu'ils auraient pu jouer
ici f3 et la menace c'est de jouer par
une 3e 3 et deux échecs suivi de dames
tout simplement
hélas les blancs sort est quasiment
obligé de de jouer foufou des cinq
échecs
bref 4 et de prendre le pion f3 puisque
la menace f2 échec la f1 cavaliers maths
qui a valu aux trois matches est trop
forte donc là il faudrait prendre en f3
et après roy prend f3 il ya toujours des
menaces qu il ya toujours des menaces il
ya toujours des menaces de maths il faut
faire attention
là les noirs menace par exemple
imaginons que les blancs jouent un coup
comme à 6 la sematra regarder ton j'ai
deux échecs
sirois chain cavale et g3 mc et sirois
f1 c'est l'autre côté combat cavaliers
ou trois échecs
tour à tour eu deux essais mat
vous voyez comme l'activité des pièces
peut contrebalancer un des avantages
matériels
ce café marie petit à petit elle finit
même par avantage par avoir un avantage
matériel à la fin donc ici f3 alors
après tourbe et de pardon 3e donc et
paroisse j'ai eu mon à vue parce que ça
perd alors c'est pas la même en em parce
qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
menaces de maths on va le voir tout de
suite parce que marie joue quand même f3
menace f2 échec froid et faim force et
sinon ces dames et cavaliers ou trois
matches c'est chaud à noter qu'un coup
comme fou c4 marche pas ici puisque sur
f3 fous ces quatre d'accord ces perdants
quand même f2 échec
sirois f1 il ya cavaliers ou trois qui
fait maths ça craint donc il faut jouer
le roi des huns d'accord et là regardez
c'est simple cavaliers aux trois échecs
ouah c'est un et forcé et maintenant
tour ces deux échecs et approuvera bien
simplement on prend le faut et c'est
terminé puisque en plus on va faire dame
derrière donc la tour aussi il sera
perdu
et donc c'est chaud
3 il faut faire attention ya pas dix
mille conte pour les blancs ici et là
heureusement les blancs de troubles seul
coup ou g6 g6 tranquillement il faut
éliminer ce cavalier
à noter que alors là aussi il faut
connaître ses finale deux tours
on est dans une finale de type philidor
si on élimine faux et cavaliers
justement donc là le câline neutraliser
puisqu'il tout et on échangera le pion
passé avec une tour face à l'endroit ne
gagne pas du moins que le roi est devant
voilà donc encore une fois la fameuse
position de philidor des finales de
tours on y est c'est à dire que là du
moment que les que les noirs ont poussé
le pion sur la sur la troisième est que
le roi blanc est devant on ne peut pas
gagner donc les blancs sont confiants
aussi je pense après forget s'ils savent
qu'ils vont tenir la partie
clamart y joue quand même tour à 2 faut
prendre cavaliers échec
on va prendre tour 17 alors attention ça
attaque bien entendu à cette simplement
tour prend 1,5 et l'a simplement
regarder brave de l'eiblen mon ami sont
tranquilles ils savent très bien que
c'est nul ici et 9 pas défendre f3 de
façon efficace un tour à 3 et l'a
simplement de tours échec
le touriste chèques alors à noter que
heureusement qu'il reste le pian h ce
pion et contrebalance le pion à ici mais
aussi ce pion a de toute façon n'est pas
suffisamment loin par rapport au roi
c'est à dire qu'on va voir que les
blancs là de toute façon peuvent
l'arrêter
sachant qu'en plus le pion à chis y
oblige le roi noir d'un rester en quoi
peut pas bloquer l'avancée du plan du
rendement durable en donc on va voir ça
roi ou quatre bons pour empêcher la
perte mais simplement encore un échec
bref quatre tours et cet échec et la
marie bon ben c'est bien que si elle
jouera aucun autre baisse à maféré nul
et si elle jouera à 1,5 alors s'il
jouera cinq il faut sans doute pas
prendre il faut pas après on ici en f3
ça serait perdu ça serait perdu il faut
simplement avec les blancs joué le coup
h4 il faut simplement pousser ses pions
ce qui oblige les noirs fait qu'à faire
quelque chose parce que là le plus loin
et eurent bloqué par la toux ou en bus
donc là on bouge on bouge on bouge et il
faut que les noirs fasse quelque chose
donc on va être obligé de lâcher la pris
la défense du f3 et c'est nul donc on
revient la position f4 taux refi cet
échec roi g5 prendre simplement
maintenant on peut prendre parce que le
roi et en gsm n'empêche pas le roi blanc
d'aller chercher pions 1 donc on peut
prendre f3 marie pons quand même échec
pour apprendre et après à 5 3 à 4 3 des
trois on voit que le roi arrive à
arrêter le pion à trois rois c'est 2 à 2
roy b2 tranquillement des prix roi h4 la
partie est nul entre les deux joueuses
magnifique partie je crois que là on a
une magnifique partie de championnat du
monde entre deux joueuses de très très
bon niveau avec les blancs qui ont pris
un net avantage à l'ouverture on l'a vu
les noirs étaient resserrés et on a vu
comment
marie sebag a réussi à jouer sa chance
en affaiblissant le roi blanc petit à
petit et en essayant de monter en
initiatives alors réussi à activer ses
pièces et il a suffi d'une imprécision
une seule précision des blancs pour que
les noirs reviennent dans la partie et
les noirs qui ont d'ailleurs aussi
failli quasiment renversait totalement
la vapeur et même gagné la partie
si eux mêmes n'avaient pas fait quelques
imprécisions on l'a vu en finale mais
les bleues ont souffert jusqu'au bout
après avoir dominé le début de partie
pour essayer d'annuler ensuite on a vu
voilà donc très beau score peut-être
très belle partie en tout cas le score
nul assure maintenant pour marie sebag
la tenue des tie break ce qui était
quand même un résultat souhaitable elle
avait les noirs aujourd'hui donc c'était
parce qu'elle pouvait espérer sans doute
de mieux si ce n'est bien sûr l'emporter
bon à deux doigts de pouvoir le faire
pourquoi pas mais elle aurait pu aussi
perdre les tie-breaks vont être
passionnant c'est quand une place en
huitièmes de finale qui va jouer c'est
des parties rapides
marie est extrêmement forte en partie
rapide on peut se rappeler des matches
nuls qu'elle a fait en partie rapide
face à l'atonie karpov elle a réussi
aussi à mettre en difficulté laurent
frayssinet de est en général le joue à
un niveau extrêmement élevé en partie
rapide et elle est capable de sortir des
parties extraordinaire donc on peut
supposer qu'en partie rapide là par
contre marie est clairement et bien
favorite 1 du match étant donné ce
qu'elle a déjà démontré dans le passé à
ce niveau là voilà merci à tous d'avoir
suivi sur des modèles tv ce petit résumé
des seizièmes de finale du championnat
du monde féminin entre marie sebag et
donc et hanau chez nina match nul et tie
break à venir au revoir